hey buddy it's Mike from orderflows and
welcome to today's video It's Friday
October 21st of 2022 and you know this
Market is it's insane you know if the
market did the same thing every day all
the time well we'd pretty much have it
all figured out right and hopefully
we'll be rolling in the dough but then
again we'd also be bored and this Market
uh definitely is not a market that is
going to bore you you know um starting
from about uh just before seven o'clock
or sorry just for eight o'clock we had
you know a nice big pump off of about 40
points pulled back about uh 25 then
another big pump of uh another 40 and
then pull back and another big uh rally
um you know going up into uh where we
are right now we're up about 70 uh
points and I'll talk about some of the
things here that was happening in the
order flow
uh just as this Market was uh getting
ready to
jump up about 40 points and the the
second rally of about 40 points and you
know for those of you that are you know
sort of new to the markets I mean
honestly I don't think people that watch
my videos are relatively new to the
markets but you know what we're seeing
here happen you know these are big moves
right don't don't underestimate these
moves that you're seeing here these are
very fast moves and if you're caught
offsides you know if you're short going
into this rally it's just uh it's gonna
it's brutal if you don't have a stop in
there you know I always recommend you
have to have a stop in the market
um you know just to prevent you know to
save you from yourself when there are
these big moves you know because a lot
of times you know the markets were just
moving having these small little
movements now again this is a five
minute bar chart before I jump into the
order flow but you know most of the time
this is what we're expecting what was
happening here but now you're seeing
these bars with 15 uh Point ranges which
is you know it's quite big and again if
you're not using a stop you're going to
get your head handed back to you uh on a
stake so let's just sort of go back to
around the seven o'clock time
you know Market was coming in down into
our first lows of the day here and we
hit our we're coming in around this 43
uh we came down here this was a new low
at the time 42 and a quarter and as
we're coming in here we're starting to
see some signs of of buying coming in in
terms of if you're looking at the Deltas
the Delta volume percentages are quite
strong you know 26 44. you know we got a
couple negative ones in here which you
know minus 25 minus 37 but again you're
right you're low you're expecting to see
selling
um when you start to see buying coming
in at the lows and and strong buying at
that you know that's what these teal uh
cells are is telling you these this
buying that you're seeing coming in is
strong relative to the volume in the bar
that's taking place and we actually got
a Divergence here we're at at this point
this was the low of the day 42 and a
quarter
and you got positive Delta 131 at the
low of the day all right so that's in
itself is generally a bullish sign and
then you're going to add in some of the
order flow to it
um you know you got a bullish order flow
ratio right here 0.23
um it's reading what's happening in the
order flow it's giving you that blue
number there
and
to me that's generally a nice Buy Signal
right the market did rally up a little
bit
um you know from that 44-ish area up
into the 48s and just sort of hung
around then we started pulling back and
going sideways okay so at that point you
know just okay
you know take what you can out of the
trade and wait for the Cash open now
right before the cash open again we got
this nice big uh pump up here but again
you know if you're getting long off this
this low here right it's one thing to
say oh yeah you know you should have
been buying it in here at 44 and you
know holding it all this time and then
um you know finally you got that big run
up here you know
that was at 720
right the best trades
move quickly in your favor they don't
just sort of go up come back down hang
around your entry price for a half hour
and then you know miraculously start
making their move you know there's so
much other order flow that's coming into
the market right if you're long off that
low at 44 you know call 44 44 and a half
and gets up to 48 and then just sort of
lingers around right comes back down
even to 43 back up to 47. just sort of
hanging around you know hindsight's 2020
and you can look back and say well yeah
you see the market ran 50 points yeah
but then in the meantime before it ran
there it's just rotating aimlessly
around you know your entry price you
know maybe you could have got a few
points out of it you know maybe you know
you caught this pop but you know
realistically you should only got a few
points out of it
um you know if you're a scalper right
scalpers yeah I see people use that term
yeah I'm a scalper but then they hold
the trades for 15 20 30 minutes you know
that's not by definition scalping that's
day trading
so anyway
um you know we made this new low here we
started coming down to two and a quarter
again and we had another Divergence then
came down to our low of the day at uh
one and a half 41 and a half here and
then we start seeing the aggressive
buying start coming in what do we see we
see uh stacked buying and balance here
this Bar's actually got four binding
balances uh one two three four
you know it's got strong Delta relative
to volume
and we're closing near our Max Deltas
right which is also a very good sign I
mean our Deltas closing at 225 our Max
Delta is 228 so we know that
you know this bar is dominated by
aggressive buyers obviously the next bar
similar story right we've got a final
Delta of 362 Max Delta of 362. we're
closing right on our our strongest Delta
reading and the market pulls back for a
couple bars okay fine you know it's not
the end of the world oh my gosh you know
I got two red candles I hang it out it
would run for the you know you gotta
give a trade a chance rather than uh the
first sign of of selling coming in uh
you know I'm wrong I can get out and
then boom the next bar double stacked in
balance in the bar very strong Delta 543
relative to Max Delta which is 548 Delta
into the volume again 42 right another
strong number that's why you know the
strong numbers that are bullish are
colored
um cyan the bearish ones are colored uh
magenta okay and then the market starts
railing right we're seeing bullish ratio
bullish ratio that's this 38 that's this
zero in here you're starting to see
again strong Deltas coming in here one
two three out of these four bars you
know this one was also strong 294 but it
wasn't as close and near our
Max Delta but then look at this also
this is interesting the Min Delta
numbers
zero zero zero what that means is
doesn't mean that there was no selling
rather what it means is that there was
no
um
Min Delta in the bar meaning that
sellers took control of the bar from the
aggressive buyers right I mean people
are selling
into the bid price in here right there's
there's two-way auction trading going on
but at no point were they ever in
control to turn the Delta negative right
and that's a bullish sign right if if
sellers are are there when sellers are
going to be there but if they're not
strong enough to turn it from positive
to negative meaning the Delta from
positive to negative
what do you think is happening you know
there's strong buying right strong
buying tends to
deal with a strong buying or strong
selling it tends to continue in that
direction so if it's strong buying it's
generally going to continue in that
direction until something stops it right
just as if there was going to be strong
selling what's going to stop it well
you're going to need the selling one to
weaken and two strong buying to come in
okay so we rally right we Rally from you
know this is basically this 40 well this
can you call it this bar here 55 right
55 all the way up to 80. you can do that
and again this is a 30 second chart so
we're talking we'll call it 55 here at 8
o'clock
803 right we rally
um from 55 up to 80. right that's a
that's a very fast move
um very nice obviously we got this
stacked in balance in this bar in here
right right here
all right we had that one earlier double
stacked imbalance you can see when the
market is moving directionally what are
you looking for obviously the Deltas are
the first sign then you got to start
looking at point of controls point of
control is obviously going higher higher
higher right a little pullback here then
higher higher higher higher it's a
little lower here and then higher higher
now we got our first big sign of selling
coming in here at 803.
we've got
here right this was a
a bar with very strong negative Delta
minus 642
you got that stacks on and balance and
the market starts selling off a little
bit right some strong selling coming in
here in these two bars right you see the
magenta okay maybe this Market's going
to fall over then it starts reversing
again all right so again if you're short
in here you got to watch you still got
to manage the trade I mean once you're
in the trade doesn't mean that's it I'm
done I go uh enter my stop loss and my
take profit then go you know go out and
have breakfast no you'll manage the
trade that's what Traders do that's how
you get paid is is managing your trades
all right so then we
start seeing the market turn around and
as we're turning around what's the first
sign well point of controls are going
higher and these three bars so again if
you're short in here you should have a
stop probably the first place you're
going to do hide behind is this stacked
Salina balance
and if you did you'd have been stopped
out fine okay you get stopped out I mean
Traders get stopped out you know being
stopped out isn't the end of the world
that's part of trading you're going to
have bad trades and
there's signs of very strong aggressive
buying coming in you can see the Deltas
are magenta four in a row here even in
this bar you have the
um no Min Delta zero right which
indicates a strong uh directional buying
obviously you got the four or five uh
bind imbalances in this bar and the
market pops up starts making new highs
now we're sort of getting into that
period before Cash open okay because at
this point you know we're coming into 8
um you know in the
sort of the the 20 years ago gosh
one of the 20 years ago
when there's still the the open outcry
pretty active in Globex traded overnight
s p is traded until uh age 15 so you
know once you start getting into this 8
15 period I mean when I say they trade
till 8 15. you traded on Globex until 8
15 and then glovex stopped but then the
pit would open at 8 30. so
um I mean now it's it's continuous but
you know I've just sort of been trained
ever since you know since Globex started
when I've been trading electronically
that are you know there's that sort of
that that shoulder time when you know
Traders are starting getting ready for
the Cash open and that's why you tend to
see the volumes between you know 8 15
and 8 30 start to really uh quiet down
right you can see in here right the
volumes were four thousand twenty eight
hundred five thousand and then you know
that 8 15 time now people are sort of
getting prepared
for the Cash open you see the volumes
are cut in half uh you know 1600 2800
1500 1400 you know 1700
um you know Traders are just getting
ready for the Cash open
all right so boom cash opens and we
trade all the way down we start coming
off here
um we sell off doesn't look like much
again this is a 30 second chart but it's
a move from basically
um you know 73 74 down to 56. again
almost a 20 point move and it starts
reversing right you know what sort of
day you're going to be looking at in
terms of volatility where this Market
can have very fast moves when you know
some of these initial bars you know
you're talking
um you know 10 point bars right off the
bat right off the cash 10 point bars on
a 30 second chart you know this one
right here right it's 59 and a quarter
all the way up to 71 and three quarters
okay so you know what sort of day you're
coming into right again I've talked
about this in the past understanding
early
if a days it's got some volatility or
not I mean the vix you know in my
opinion is very misleading it's at 30
well 29 Sudden Change but um you know
essentially 30 and it's actually down
um
since the the day before believe it or
not but um I mean we've sort of just
been hanging around just under 30 just
sort of like this Bitcoin you know
what's Bitcoin gonna do we're hanging
around 19 000 you know dips below into
the eight you know 18 000 nine something
but it just doesn't break down
um and the vix sort of it's the opposite
right and just we hit 30 000 or sorry
thirty thousand Jesus Christ I think we
got 30 000 effects you get up to 30 in
the vix
um we just sort of come right back off
of it okay
but again you're understanding now we
could be in for a uh rock and roll day
and this Market it didn't disappoint
okay we get right in here
again we're seeing some bullish signs in
the order flow right we're seeing
bullish Eva bullish engulfing value
that's why this is blue this one is blue
this one is bearish and then blue here
right it's telling you it's bullish this
one no follow through this one you got
what one tick follow through
I like to see at least two ticks follow
through because if you have something
that's bullish in the order flow you
need that follow through right and
because once you get into a trade that's
it that's all you can do as a Trader you
can analyze the market
but then you can't do anything else once
you're in the trade you know it means me
you could add on a position but there's
nothing that you can do to get the
market to move in your favor now it's in
the hands of the other Traders sort of
having a either bullish or bearish view
of the market and again you know you've
got something bullish here in the order
flow but no follow-through one tick
higher and then it sort of starts coming
down now we got the bearish value area
next bar goes inside not a good sign
right if you have something very bullish
in the order flow or anything no matter
what you're trading you've got a very
bullish sign and then all of a sudden
the market goes inside on the next bar
that's not a good sign for you right you
want the market to start moving
sooner rather than later
and then so two up two bars later it
starts coming off right you got that
nice Red Bar okay man it gets short then
it comes right back with the nice
bullish value area here this this blue
box in this bar which is a very strong
sign and
you get the follow through
okay actually trades all the way up to
71. and then it comes right back down to
60 you know in the 68 67 area
but really what you're going to do right
if you got short off of this bearish
value area you're getting short around
63 you know by the time you get this
bullish one right you got to be getting
out worst case you know 68 and a half
69. now you got a nice bullish sign you
got to get long and then this Market
just does the
the
amazing jump right
it goes from basically 68
straight up I mean it's a vertical move
um in this bar 68 all the way up to 72
next bar all the way up to 74 and then
the big bar up here you know from 74 all
the way up to 85 and just keeps going up
and up and up you know it's one of those
things where
um the movies happen so fast that you
get
you get your take profit filled anything
you're kind of thinking gosh you know I
wish I was able to adjust it to go
higher it's one of those things damned
if you do damned if you don't you know
it's a greed factor in a way
um
but you don't fall into that trap it's
like oh yeah I should have adjusted it
because you know sometimes you adjust it
and
the original take profit would have been
uh sufficient and then the market turns
around and sells off but this one was
just a brilliant move up from this 68
area all the way
up into the the 96 but again you know
what were the signs
in the order flow okay well this one the
other order flow is kind of mixed I mean
what you're looking at is the value area
in the bar right based off of the order
flow which is telling you that where 70
of the volume is and it's telling you
that this bar has got a very bullish
order flow
okay that's why it's colored blue
I just this one had bearish one but it
it just it's like the the switch got
turned right you had something very
bearish here which turned very bullish
now this time the market ran with it all
right and just goes up and up and up but
again you know looking at the Deltas you
know here you got the negative 244
people say well Mike you know you're
buying it into a bar that's got negative
Delta well yeah but it's coming in after
a bar with very strong order flow in
terms of the value area which is very
bullish in this bar even though it's got
a small Delta but again 44
in Delta is a relatively benign number
all right I treat especially if I'm
looking at the e-minis you know the
Delta number of less than 50 as
generally neutral in terms of I'm not
negative on it I'm not positive on it
it's just you know it is it is what it
is and then you got the red bar with
negative Delta okay fine I got a red bar
with negative Delta that's what I expect
to see and then the next bar again more
buying imbalances to
obviously opponent controls higher
the next bar Point control is higher so
even if you missed your entry here you
know we're starting opponent controls
I've gotten one from this one here it's
higher higher higher higher so you've
already got four higher pointed controls
the Deltas are decent you know 184 153
this one obviously very strong 1520
um you know multiple bind imbalances
again you could have gotten long in any
of these two other green candles here I
wasn't expecting a 10 point move in the
next bar but you know you got to be in
the position to take advantage of it
yeah I I'm more scared to buy after this
10-point move here
right for another 10 point move even
though you did get it but you know
really if you know you got the bullish
sign right here and how does this bar
differ right you're gonna say well why
didn't you buy here or here well you got
no follow-through order flow on this
first one right you just go inside
this one you only want one tick higher
right you got multiple buying imbalances
in here one two three four bullish order
flow in terms of the value area
obviously positive Delta okay I'm
looking for this Market to start moving
it didn't selling came in right you let
one tick higher than the high of this
bar you know if you've been following me
for any period of time you know that
when I see something bullish in the
order flow I'm waiting for the market to
continue right more buying to come in if
it's bullish or more selling if it's
bearish and the buying didn't come in
off this bullish bar which is I don't
say a bearish sign but it's not a
positive sign in the sense that
um you know I'm going to get long right
if the Market opens up trades one tick
higher then immediately starts
collapsing
um that's not a good sign okay but this
bar here right you got the bullish order
flow next bar
starts rallying right which is what you
want to see I mean did pull back a
little bit did you know the high was 68
of this bar so again we opened up at 67
and three quarters traded all the way up
to 71 and a half and then we pulled back
down to 66 and a quarter
so you know you're about two points
underwater but still it's not the end of
the world right so oh you know I'm
taking some heat because the market
snapped right back and boom took off
so anyway guys again I could go on and
on about this this day it's just been an
insane day I said these days sometimes
they feel like you've been in a
wrestling match by the time you get done
with the um with the session or you just
like get to lunch you know and get to
lunch in one piece that's great
so anyway guys I'll end that video for
now so be sure to like in the video and
hit subscribe and you know I'll try to
get you guys a bunch more videos out
there thanks everyone have a great
weekend bye bye